what is the box plot with a box plot you
can graphically display a lot of
information about your data but what is
displayed in a box plot the Box
indicates the range in which the middle
50 of all values lie thus the lower end
of the box is the first quartile and the
upper end is the third quartile
therefore 25 percent of the data are
above Q3 in the Box we find fifty
percent of our data and 25 of the data
are below q1 the range between q1 and Q3
is called interquartile range the solid
line indicates the median the dashed
line shows the mean the upper t-shaped
whiskers indicate the last point which
is still within 1.5 times the
interquartile range so if there is no
outlier this is the maximum value points
that are further away are considered as
outliers